just clarify what is the situation
what's happening in Leicester what is
central government telling you to do
well as you say we've had a copy of a
report centres overnight it despite all
of our asking does not explain why they
feel that it is necessary to take some
special action here in Leicester and I'm
not saying we shouldn't take special
action I'm just saying that I and the
people of Leicester would need to be
convinced that there was something
unique about our city before we agreed
to an extension of the lockdown
I'm also obviously you know recognized
that we do need to continue to take
effective measures to warn people of the
dangers that they continue eight-nation
of the virus in our city and we'll
continue to do that and work with
government to do that but if we are to
have special treatment we need the
evidence to just right and as I
understand it this email asked you to
keep in place the present restrictions
beyond Saturday beyond the 4th of July
for another two weeks are you saying
you're not prepared to do that I'm
saying we need to be convinced that
there is a case for doing that first of
all that there is something special
about the the spread of the virus in
Leicester we've had no evidence to to
convince that that and that if blessed
it was to remain restricted for longer
than the rest of England that that would
actually make a difference to something
and they've made neither the case that
there is something that needs to be done
and given any explanation as to why this
is the right thing to do well the case
as I understand it is that there has
been a high incidence of people testing
positive in in Leicester and
particularly amongst younger age groups
and that therefore that is a cause of
concern because they don't want it to
spread
well actually the report that we've had
from them readily acknowledges right at
the outset that in fact the results are
indeed higher in Leicester but that's
because they've been doing more testing
in Leicester and that's perhaps is a
fairly inevitable reflection of what's
been happening but having acknowledged
that at the beginning of the report they
then go on to make some recommendations
for actually continuation of the present
restriction in Leicester beyond the
fourth of July that are not supported by
any of the of the evidence that they've
provided but as we've just got a quote
from that document you received
overnight delaying the 4th of July 2020
relax and relaxation actions in
Leicester an enhancement of enforcement
or monitoring of social distancing
guidelines for at least two weeks I mean
that that is the straightforward request
and I mean what you're going to do
you're going to go back to the
government and sort of argue the toss
with them
well at the moment that report is some
recommendations from public health
England and I don't know whether the
government has had a chance yet to
decide whether or not to act on those
recommendations here from Priti Patel
yesterday I'm up yeah no but that was
that was about a lockdown which is quite
a long way from a an extension for two
weeks of the of the present level of
restriction and that was a very dramatic
claim that somehow something very
dramatic was going to happen in
Leicester in fact what we've got now is
a comparatively modest proposal but even
with that modest proposal it's something
that will have a significant effect on
the on the people of Leicester while the
rest of England is coming out of
lockdown we would somehow have to remain
within it well that's fine if it is
necessary if they can prove it's
necessary of course we go for it but
they have not provided the evidence that
it is necessary or that it would make
any difference do you actually have the
capacity both in legal terms and also in
terms of resources to maintain a
lockdown if that's what it comes to well
as I say this is a report from public
health England and it would really be
for the government's to explain if we
were to continue the lockdown in
Leicester how they would enforce it
which parts of the city they would
enforce it in and who would be
responsible of making sure their works I
think I hope that they will first of all
our provides to the evidence for why it
might be necessary but then explain to
us how on earth it could be made to
happen so as things stand the pubs in
Leicester and those other public places
they will open on Saturday as far as
you're concerned
well certainly that is what is happening
across England on Saturday the fourth of
July and they will I expect unless we
get instructions to the country be
happening here as they ought to be along
with the rest of England I mean the fact
is that the figures that we do have that
are reliable because for hospital
admissions the figures sadly for deaths
in Leicester show a decline in the
impact of the virus unless though that
is very very similar to what is
happening across the whole of England
and they certainly don't suggest that
there are particular issues here that
need to be dealt with in some
dramatically different way